[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
livrer des avions à l'ukraine un sujet
qui enflamme les médias américains et
embarrasse le gouvernement ce matin les
etats unis ont refusé une proposition
polonaise allant dans ce sens mais alors
quand est-ce que ces avions vont arriver
quand est ce qu'une décision sera prise
nous sommes en temps de guerre nous
n'avons pas de temps pour ses
contradictions depuis ce matin
l'alimentation électrique du site de
tchernobyl au nord de l'ukraine est
totalement coupée en raison d'actions
militaires russes dans la zone pourquoi
est ce que les américains qui depuis
huit ans conseille la présidence
ukrainienne ne l'ont pas mise en garde
sur le danger qu'il y avait à rentrer
dans un rapport de force direct avec les
rues et pourquoi pourquoi est-ce qu'ils
n'ont pas incité à signer et pons accord
à respecter la signature qu'il avait
donné des accords demi masqué
diamantifère dépensés par les amants
coiffe situation inquiétante alors que
depuis 14 jours la centrale est aux
mains de l'armée russe plus de 200
gardes des techniciens travaillent sous
leurs ordres sans bénéficier de relais
américain était considère que l'ukraine
est un bon moyen d'affaiblir la russie
et de continuer la vieille guerre qui
est menée depuis le clairement il faut
le dire parce que les gens c'est un
langage qui est pris c'est une espèce de
c'est le dernier run une sorte de guerre
froide
une cyberattaque possiblement russe a
frappé spotify
la plateforme de streaming suédois se
connaît une série de bugs qui empêchent
de nombreux utilisateurs d'écouter leur
musique ce soit la gravité de la
situation internationale la chine et la
russie maintiendront leurs orientations
stratégiques et seront progresser leur
partenariat anonymous a de son côté
contre-attaqué en piratant des
télévisions russes dans ce contexte il
n'y a qu'une décision majeure qui doit
être prise c'est de suspendre d'arrêter
les livraisons de gaz et de pétrole
venant de russie faisait ce levier c'est
sanctionner très gravement très
lourdement les français les entreprises
françaises l'économie française qui
pourrait mettre des années à se relever
après la nouvelle sanction prise ce
matin par l'europe contre la russie
cette dernière pourrait être en défaut
de paiement dans les heures qui viennent
en clair elle serait incapable de
rembourser ses dettes à changer nos
modes de consommation et nos
approvisionnements et à faire remonter
plus rapidement les renouvelables et
aussi d'utiliser plus bas sivement le
nucléaire dans ces cas life avec
monsieur hollande ne fermait pas
fessenheim parce que tous ces gens ils
ont en réalité attaqué le nucléaire
français y compris emmanuel macron début
de son mandat qui voulait fermer 14
réacteurs nucléaires si jean luc
mélenchon était au second tour de la
présidentielle
il est désormais troisième d attention
de votre premier tour pourquoi n'y a
plus jamais la moindre sanction sur le
pétrole saoudien quand les saoudiens ont
attaqué le yémen est pas une fois ça
dure depuis plus d'un an et demi le
moyen qui consiste à se faire hara kiri
pour blesser l'adversaire est un mauvais
moyen nous risquons qui marche des
affaires se nourrir notre économie avant
celle de la russie puisqu'il semblerait
que ce soit l'objectif de bruno le maire
qui bien que ce n'est pas exagéré que de
dire que cette crise énergétique ce choc
énergétique de 2022 est comparable en
intensité en brutalité au choc pétrolier
de 1973 après le prêt à porter et le
luxe ce sont les enseignes américaine de
fast food qui prennent le large avec
starbucks kfc ou encore mcdonald's hier
soir il y avait foule pour tenter de
manger un dernier hamburger à moscou
jeudi à l'électeur écoute moi je me
bouge en rejetant le cul tu as aussi
bouge toi le cul si tu les laisses faire
il tend déjà tout préparé tu sais déjà à
la finale que tu auras et le vainqueur
que tu auras ça y est c'est oublié